what's up everybody welcome to another
Python tutorial video in this video I'm
gonna be showing you guys the try
accepts else which is best thought of as
the quote unquote accept else because if
the accept is not triggered the else
will run you can think of the accept
else as if it is the if elsewhere except
well where if is except in else's else
so here's a quick example and again kind
of different from the while else and the
for else in the sense that if accept
doesn't run right if accept is never
triggered else will run so there's
absolutely no need for a break and if
you put a break in there you're gonna
get a syntax error so so there's that so
anyways let's go ahead and get started
with try except else so we're gonna say
try and for now let's just say x equals
three plus three so it's gonna try to do
this and if it can cannot do it then
except print
well that try accept and then else so
else again if exception if the exception
is not triggered then it's gonna do this
else statement else print runs only when
there is no exception right so if the
try is successful the else will run
otherwise because like except is so it's
kind of like a way that like if the
try-works
that we want to do the else statement
and if the try doesn't work then we want
to do the exception of course right so
it's just an easy way to do try and
except otherwise you can do try x equals
let's say three plus three and then you
can put some code down here and you know
continue and engage with whatever you
were trying to do but for some
situations that actually isn't the best
way to go about it so you get double
code and I'll actually be talking a
little bit more about that shortly but
first I want to go ahead and run this so
let's say x equals three plus three
run this maybe there we go so it comes
up runs only when there is no exception
so there was no exception right but if
we said x equals let's say X plus three
right X was never defined the trial will
not work we'll hit the exception well
that didn't work and we will not run the
else statement so let's run this and
again well that didn't work so we knew
that but the else statement is there for
some added functionality right so in
this scenario the else statement is only
triggered when the exception is not so
let's say you're you actually are
manipulating variables so you might
decide well hey I want to try to do it
this way so try x equals x plus 3 except
if that didn't work then we would say x
equals 3 plus 3 right and then else
maybe we do something else
and continue running the script or do
whatever we would do if there was no
exception for example so now what if you
wanted to maybe always run something
after the try and except yeah you want
the outcome of like they're trying to
except to actually effect it right so
it's gonna run every time but whether
the try or except is triggering it maybe
acts a little bit differently so you
could put the same code like under the
try and the accept or you could have
like a variable at the top you know
that's defined bar you know x equals or
actually I guess you just say x equals
you know for starters you can say 0 I
guess and then you could have the try
you know redefine the X or the exception
redefine the X and you can continue with
the code again not the most pythonic way
and actually the incorrect way so
basically what the question is how would
you get it to run every time either
whether or not the trier except is
triggering the else and all that you can
actually put all of the code underneath
like a try except and a finally
statement so no matter what if the try
is triggered it does something if the
exception is triggered it does something
and
which one is triggered it will run the
finally okay so that's what we're going
to be talking about in the next video
so try accept finally as always thanks
for watching things for all the support
in the subscriptions and until next time